My first system was NES,
I think when I was like
five or six years old,
seven maybe, and, you know, I
just fell in love with that.
Just playing Super Mario
and, and one through three,
three still being one
of probably my favorite
game of all time.
Super Mario World is climbing
it because me and my wife,
we played that before we got married,
that was one of the prerequisites
of our marriage that we had to make sure
that we could get through
Super Mario World together.
That's a great test.
We have to beat Super Mario
World 2: Yoshi's Island
in order to have a child,
because that only makes sense.
And that's, I'm very
happy to have a format
where I could tell that
joke and not explain it
and people will get it.
Yes, exactly.
It's a safe place here.